Trascrizione: Katherine Wolf
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Sono molto felice di parlarvi, oggi,
di Intelligenza Artificiale,
che di fatto è un tema
che studio, utilizzo, sviluppo
ed insegno da più di 30 anni
e che è una tecnologia
che è diventata pervasiva
nella vita di tutti noi,
e ci servirà per migliorare
la vita di tutti noi.
Nel bene e nel male, naturalmente.
In questi minuti vi parlerò
del bene, e non del male,
perché sono fermamente convinta
che una tecnologia come questa -
come tutte le tecnologie! -
se utilizzata in modo
corretto, responsabile,
corretto per le nostre leggi
e per la nostra etica,
possa davvero fare bene alla nostra vita.
Questo vale per tutte le tecnologie,
ma vale ancor di più
per l'Intelligenza Artificiale,
che nasce dagli esseri umani
e impara a modellare la nostra conoscenza
e la nostra esperienza,
ed è quindi estremamente
vicina alla nostra vita.
Ed è proprio per questo
che il titolo di questo mio talk
è "L'intelligenza non è artificiale",
perché credo fermamente
che l'Intelligenza Artificiale
non sia artificiale,
ma sia il frutto dell'uomo,
degli ingegneri che la progettano,
di chi la modella
e di chi ha la responsabilità
di insegnare, attraverso i dati,
attraverso l'ottimizzazione di queste,
i migliori aspetti che possono
essere portati in un mondo artificiale.
D'altra parte l'AI,
l'Intelligenza Artificiale -
ora userò questo termine -
non è soltanto ricerca,
come siamo abituati a fare
all'interno dell'università;
ma è pervasiva, ed è diventata
una serie di prodotti.
E probabilmente, tutti noi lo sappiamo,
abbiamo già migliaia
di Intelligenze Artificiali
che vivono attorno a noi,
e che influenzano le nostre vite.
Vi faccio soltanto alcuni esempi,
per farvi capire di che cosa sto parlando.
Pensate, per esempio,
a tutto quello che utilizzate giornalmente
nei calcolatori,
negli smartphone, ovunque:
tutte le suite di Google,
per esempio, di Amazon
o di tutte le altre
grandi case costruttrici,
che riconoscono il parlato
e possiamo parlare con Siri,
con Alexa, con Google Home;
riconoscono il volto,
ricostruiscono in 3D
in Street View o in Google Map
tutte le nostre case e le nostre attività;
riconoscono le nostre impronte digitali
o analizzano i nostri testi.
E tutto questo fa parte
della grande categoria
dell'Intelligenza Artificiale,
così come fanno parte della categoria
dei sistemi di Intelligenza Artificiale
le auto che guidano da sole
e che quindi riescono
a riconoscere il mondo esterno
per dare un input
alla guida e allo sterzo.
Così come, purtroppo, lo sono i droni
che ultimamente, lo sappiamo,
in Libia sono stati utilizzati
come armi di distruzione di massa
per riconoscere le persone.
Ma non sono gli aspetti negativi
che mi interessano,
perché in compenso pensiamo
a tutti i robot semplici,
dotati di Intelligenza Artificiale,
che vengono invece utilizzati
per i bambini autistici,
per poter imparare con loro,
e assieme a loro,
come interfacciarsi con le persone.
Sono sistemi di Intelligenza Artificiale
tutti i sistemi di Fintech,
di analisi dei dati
negli ambienti di produzione
e di ottimizzazione della produzione.
Pensate, per esempio,
a tutto il mondo
del "Predictive Analytics",
che riguarda la possibilità
di analizzare i dati di produzione
e che tutte le analisi
di mercato ci dicono
che nei prossimi cinque anni
avrà un incremento
fino al 21, 22 percento,
dal punto di vista dell'incremento
delle vendite e della costruzione.
Tutti questi esempi sono esempi classici
di Intelligenza Artificiale;
ma forse, l'esempio più importante
in quest'ultimo periodo
è l'esempio dell'utilizzo
dell'Intelligenza Artificiale
nell'ambito della medicina,
per riconoscere nelle radiografie
se c'è la presenza di CoVid
o di altre malattie;
ma per riconoscere, in tutti i dati,
quello che sta succedendo.
E non solo dati immagini,
ma anche nei dati di genoma
e di tutte le altre informazioni
che derivano dal mondo della salute.
Questo è vero, quindi l'AI nasce
per analizzare i dati, comprenderli
e prevedere anche
quello che sta succedendo;
ma anche di immaginare,
perché c'è tutto un mondo
che si chiama "Generative design",
dove l'AI viene utilizzata, per esempio,
per progettare nuovi dispositivi,
per progettare nuovi farmaci;
o anche per progettare,
come stiamo facendo noi, per esempio,
nuove piastrelle o nuovi vestiti.
Vi ho dato una piccola interpretazione
di che cosa può essere
l'Intelligenza Artificiale attorno a noi.
D'altra parte, se vedete,
questo robot che sta girando
lo potete considerare anche, soltanto,
un mezzo di locomozione,
un oggetto meccanico
che però, se dotato al proprio interno
di un piccolo calcolatore
come quello che ha Tesla,
un po' di telecamere, di sensori,
può essere effettivamente
come la rappresentazione
dell'Intelligenza Artificiale,
secondo la Comunità europea, ci dice:
"Un insieme di sistemi
che vede il mondo, acquisisce dal mondo,
ha un comportamento intelligente
e intraprende azioni."
Naturalmente, per applicazioni specifiche.
Ecco, ho utilizzato questi minuti iniziali
per darvi una overview
di quello che tutti noi
consideriamo ormai AI
dal punto di vista tecnologico.
E vorrei utilizzare
i prossimi minuti, invece,
per pensare a che cos'è adesso la ricerca,
e che cosa potrà essere
nel prossimo futuro.
Ora l'AI è considerata
uno dei più grandi mezzi,
dal punto di vista del software
e dei modelli matematici,
per generalizzare
da enorme quantità di dati.
Riceve in ingresso
grandissime quantità di dati,
le elabora e ottimizza
i propri parametri interni,
che sono in generale dentro a delle reti -
che si chiamano reti neurali artificiali -
e che riesce in base a questo, poi,
a dare delle uscite, degli output,
che sono simili a quelli che potrebbero
essere comportamenti intelligenti.
Vi faccio due esempi concreti,
per essere più chiara.
Un esempio importante
è quello che si sta facendo
per la previsione del cancro
al seno a cinque anni:
non solo di riconoscere in una mammografia
se c'è o no un cancro al seno,
ma potete capire
se questo evolverà, in cinque anni,
in qualcosa di maligno e di benigno.
Nel 2019, all'MIT hanno fatto
un sistema artificiale
che imparando da decine di migliaia
di immagini di mammografie
è riuscito ad avere una previsione
corretta del 30-32 percento,
rispetto al 18-20 percento
di un essere umano,
di un medico che è capace di fare questo.
Non è ancora tanto,
però i risultati di un mese fa
sono stati quelli
che mettendo assieme
i dati americani dell'MIT,
quelli svedesi e quelli di Taiwan
si è arrivati ad un'accuratezza
fino al 45 percento.
Cosa ci dice questo?
Ci dice che se acquisiamo tantissime,
grandi quantità di dati,
sicuramente il sistema
è in grado di generalizzare
e di andare verso
una precisione sempre maggiore.
Vi faccio un secondo esempio,
che mi piace molto
perché lo stiamo sviluppando
nei nostri laboratori di Unimore.
I sistemi adesso sono in grado
non solo di capire il parlato,
ma anche di generare del testo:
ad esempio, di generare il testo
vedendo le immagini,
come in queste immagini dove,
vedendo una foto come questa,
un sistema è capace di dire che c'è
"una tazza con delle fragole tagliate
e dei mandarini pelati".
Quindi, qualcosa di estremamente concreto.
E come fa, un sistema,
a realizzare questo?
Ha imparato da tutte
le pagine di Wikipedia,
ha imparato da tutti i dati sul web.
Quindi la capacità, davvero,
di generalizzare
su grandissime quantità di dati.
Bene: io concludo, però, questo discorso
per dire che questa è la ricerca di oggi,
la produzione di oggi dell'AI
dalle grandi case costruttrici.
Ma se io vedo, spero,
quella che dovrà essere domani,
soprattutto in Italia e in Europa,
io vedo invece un'AI che dovrà essere
assolutamente iper personalizzata,
che dovrà essere individuale
e che dovrà essere unica.
Cosa intendo per questo?
Io vorrei che, in un futuro,
un robot mobile come questo,
che lavori con una persona anziana,
possa interagire con questa,
e se dice "Ho freddo"
vada direttamente a prendere
la coperta preferita,
senza dovere generalizzare su tutto quello
che gli utenti possono avere,
in generale, quando c'è freddo.
E che devono essere personalizzati
sull'esigenza, sull'etica,
sul modo di pensare dei singoli utenti,
non solo nel mondo sociale
ma anche nel mondo lavorativo.
Pensate che, nel mondo lavorativo,
noi avremo bisogno di sistemi
di Intelligenza Artificiale
capaci di conoscere il know how aziendale,
senza dovere per questo condividerlo
con quello di tutti gli altri,
senza doverlo rendere, mai, generalizzato
o federato a livello, magari,
anche di altre aziende,
di aziende straniere,
o di aziende competitor;
ma che dovrà rimanere
all'interno di chi lo ha creato.
Così come, nella Cappella Sistina,
Michelangelo era capace di realizzare
meravigliosi esseri umani tutti diversi,
dovremmo essere in grado di realizzare
meravigliosi sistemi artificiali
tutti diversi, e tutti specifici
per l'applicazione.
Quello che vi ho detto è logico:
ma non è affatto concreto,
e non è affatto facile,
dal punto di vista di un calcolatore.
E abbiamo, dal punto di vista
della ricerca, tantissime cose da fare.
Questa è una lista di nomi di tecniche
che dovremmo imparare
ad usare tutti insieme:
quelli che in inglese si chiamano
"Few Shots learning",
cioè imparare da pochissimi esempi;
"Continual Learning",
imparare in modo continuo;
"Plastic Learning", un modo
adattabile e modificabile,
come fanno i nostri neuroni.
Le reti neurali dovranno avere, perfino,
la capacità di dimenticare
o di adattarsi in base
ai secondi concessi,
e di sapersi specializzare
in modo compatibile con la privacy,
con il copyright
e con tutti i nostri valori.
Capite bene che c'è tanto da lavorare:
ma sono abbastanza convinta
che ci riusciremo,
e ci riusciremo anche in Italia;
e soprattutto, ci riusciremo
in Emilia Romagna.
Ricordiamoci che qui in Emilia Romagna
siamo all'interno di un ecosistema,
la nostra "Digital Valley",
dove abbiamo i super calcolatori
più portanti d'Europa,
abbiamo un materiale umano,
un patrimonio umano
di grandi giovani capaci
che stanno studiando queste tecnologie.
E quindi, io sono assolutamente sicura
che gli ingegneri di domani riusciranno
a realizzare sistemi AI
e risollevarsi, anche, da questa pandemia,
come ha fatto Mirandola dal terremoto,
che è un esempio assolutamente per tutti.
In un AI per tutti e in un AI, anche,
per la medicina e per la nostra vita.